kopfschmerzen und übelkeit die
unangenehmen folgen von alkohol exzessen
die sind nicht ohne aus mittel wie
salziges essen vitamin c oder kaffee
gemischt mit zitronensaft gibt es genug
doch die helfen bei einem richtigen
kater nicht wirklich ein us startup hat
jetzt ein getränk vorgestellt das mit
genmanipulierten bakterien versetzt ist
und somit einem kater vorbeugen soll
wie soll das funktionieren und ist das
nicht gefährlich links und science
fiction hier gibt's täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nun dann verpasst
er nichts los geht
herzlich willkommen in der hauptrolle
die genmanipulierten bakterien bacillus
subtilis diese mikroorganismen sind
nämlich in dem neuen probiotikum des osz
jetix vorhanden und sollen den kater der
nach übermäßigem alkoholkonsum droht
verhindern
in der fachsprache ist übrigens nicht
von kater die rede sondern von alkohol
induzierten kopfschmerzen okay der
einsatz von bakterien ein probiotikum
ist natürlich nicht neu probiotika sind
mittel die krankmachende keime aus der
darmflora entfernen und den darm
unterstützen neu ist aber dass diese
mikroorganismen erbgut enthalten das sie
in die lage versetzt acetaldehyd
abzubauen also das zwischenprodukt das
beim abbau von alkohol im körper
entsteht um bacillus subtilis mit der
notwendigen acetaldehyd dehydrogenase
auszustatten nutzen das unternehmen
nicht die berühmte richtige team gen
scheren namens chris packers 9 sondern
ein älteres verfahren bei der
sogenannten homologen rekombination wird
dna in einer zelle ausgetauscht alkohol
enthält bekannterweise ethanol und das
wird vom menschlichen stoffwechsel in
acetaldehyd umgewandelt laut den
herstellern des neuen probiotikum es ist
genau diese chemischen verbindung für
die unangenehmen kater kopfschmerzen
verantwortlich doch genau diese these
ist in der fachwelt umstritten hinzu
kommt dass das start-up bislang nicht
belegen konnte dass die gentechnisch
veränderten bakterien auch im
menschlichen körper das acetaldehyd
abbauen
dies gilt bislang nur unter
laborbedingungen als gesichert lediglich
selbst teste hersteller liegen vor
beispielsweise von dem erfinder jack
emmert er ist sich sicher
dass seine katag uhr hilft und die
unangenehmen symptome eines katers
verhindert es war ein ziemlich
anstrengendes und unterhaltsames
experiment das unternehmen empfiehlt
eine flasche des mittels vor oder
während des konsums von alkohol zu
trinken um es unter nachtschwärmer zu
bringen hatten mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen des unternehmens die
kleinen flaschen samstags in einem club
verteilt insgesamt wahnsinn angaben des
unternehmens 10.000 oben
94 prozent der nutzer hatten danach
angegeben einen nutzen erkannt zu haben
über welchen das ist vielleicht flüssig
war aber auch das start-up selbst weiß
dass das natürlich keine
wissenschaftlichen daten sind und somit
fehlen belastbare daten
das probiotikum wurde bislang eben noch
nicht in einer klinischen studie
getestet dafür fehlen nach angaben des
apz bislang noch die finanziellen mittel
dennoch ist das angebliche anti kater
getränk in den usa bereits für elf euro
zu kaufen möglich ist das war das setup
sein neues probiotikum als lebensmittel
verkaufen kann und es nicht als
medikament zählt somit ist es in den usa
nicht nötig die wirksamkeit des mittels
nachzuweisen wenigstens bezüglich der
sicherheit wurden bereits
wissenschaftliche experimente
durchgeführt in einem tierversuch wurde
raten das probiotikum 90 tage lang
gefüttert und die schienen weiterhin
gesund doch auch hier fehlt noch eine
qualitätssichernde maßnahmen die
veröffentlichung bezüglich der
sicherheit erfolgten bislang nämlich nur
in einem journal das nicht auf dem so
genannten peer review prozess basiert
somit wurde es also noch nicht durch
unabhängige forscherinnen und forscher
bewertet das steht noch aus doch nach
der offiziellen begutachtung des
fachmagazins journal of toxicology
werden wir genaueres wissen so oder so
für uns in deutschland heißt das motto
also weiterhin um den kater zu vermeiden
sollte man einfach den alkoholkonsum in
maßen gestalten und außerdem viel
flüssigkeit zu sich nehmen
die keinen alkohol enthält mein tipp
umso geringer die prozente desto größer
der spaß kennt ja ich schon mein
selbstversuch alkohol die beliebteste
droge deutschlands mit selbstversuch mit
vielen infos anklicken und bis zur
letzten sekunde gucken denn nur dann
erfahrt ihr wie viel promille ich dachte
und klicks um sein sandwich natürlich
abonnieren und die glocke aktivieren nur
dann verpassten nichts bis dann
bleibt dran